my guest tonight is a comedian and
actress who hosts the netflix series
nailed it the tbs series wipeout as well
as
five podcasts including why won't you
date me which is now part of the team
coco podcast network
we are thrilled to have her please
welcome my good friend nicole beyer hey
nicole how are you
oh conan i'm great uh i had surgery this
morning
on my ankle i still have my hospital
bracelets on
i forgot to take them off that's right
that's right you hurt your ankle what
did you do you broke it
i dislocated my ankle and broke my
fibula
because i fell down the stairs
because i'm i don't know i i guess i'm a
little clumsy
okay so there was no like drinking
involved at the time
no unfortunately it's the least
interesting story i was just holding a
dress
and then the dress kind of fell down and
i slipped on the dress
the dress was trying to take me out
right um you should sue the dress
manufacturer
you should sue the people that made the
stairs you should sue gravity
you should sue everybody everybody
should get sued
i'm i'mma sue gravity first you know
let's talk about something pandemic i
know you you're someone that likes to
have fun
you like to have a good time how are you
entertaining yourself
while you're locked inside what are you
doing a lot of things
uh well since i broke my body it's a lot
of sitting
scrolling through instagram and
buying everything i can find
really i bought a sexy burger costume uh
because why not
you bought it it's got a sexy burger
costume
like the buns the the titty parts the
buns and there's little sesame seeds
and then there's a little burger part at
the bottom and then there's lettuce and
tomatoes
it's very cute here it is and this is
you
in the burger costume and i have to say
it's sexy this is a sexy outfit thank
you
and some people commented they're like
why didn't you get it as a bikini
and i was like it's literally on over my
clothing
it is a bikini so let me ask you would
you ever wear this at the beach
see i don't think i would ever wear it
at the beach because i feel like the
salt water and the sand might ruin it
but i do think i'm gonna wear it pole
dancing
and then put a nice jaunty mcdonald's
tune under it like
maybe you know what mcdonald's people
might be happy with that they might be
cool with that
yeah and then you get a little something
you get a little paid oh yeah lots of
cheeseburgees
oh i meant money yeah milkshakes
no you don't want to get paid the food
is fine but you want money from
mcdonald's
no no you don't want to need that hey
let me ask you about this
you posted this it looks like you're
really getting into fashion
while you're in quarantine uh
i guess it's just i like in
uh november when i fell till about like
now i
truly just looked like trash so i was
like let's
dress up and that's from uh fashion
brand company
this dress i'm wearing is also from
fashion brand company
and i came downstairs and the nice man
who lives with me was like
nicole you look like patenting two goes
to jail
i've never seen paddington too but i
went on the internet
i googled and i looked just like
paddington 2 goes to jail
i see it right here
that's not just sort of like it's a
direct ripoff
paddington too i found it i was like oh
man this is a real treat it's so
funny to me have you watched paddington
2 by the way
no i haven't seen it yet but i think i'm
gonna watch it people say it's very good
let me tell you something this is a
complete side note someone explained to
me whose opinion i really respect
that it's the perfect movie in every
respect and i thought
that can't be true and i watched it and
it is i'm not kidding it is
the perfect movie on every level
i've also been told paddington 2 is
better than paddington uno
yeah no it's like uh godfather two
godfather one
the only other film to achieve that
status paddington who'd
have thought uh now someone told me
you're getting into farming
yes i'm a farmer i have tomatoes cherry
tomatoes and heirlooms
and now my cherry tomatoes they are
giving me a pretty fruitful
bounty i'm having lovely harvests just a
real treat
my heirlooms on the other hand i am not
getting a fruitful bounty
my harvests are very small and few in
between i also have a watermelon that i
grew incorrectly
too much rind not enough meat um my
cucumbers
one was good one got all f'ed up messed
up and then uh
the other one died um and then
my carrots i don't know what i'm doing
they're not thriving
um what else do i have oh i got peppers
that just won't grow
okay this is what i'm gonna say here's
the effect of quarantine on you nicole
over the years you and i have spoken
many times and you always talk at great
length about
your um well raunchy sex life
uh sexual matters you're very explicit
about um uh gentlemen that you've hooked
up with
and uh you go into great detail and i
get very embarrassed
now after almost a year of quarantine
you're talking about
tomatoes and carrots and how they're not
thriving is this the new is this the new
nicole buyer
no no no no no when
life goes back to normal which it will i
will
hop back on the dicks and i will be
riding them all day long
i cannot wait but for right now as a
lady who's scared of corona
and refuses to die for mediocre i am
farming phallic things like my cucumbers
my carrots i was told zucchinis are good
growers so i might get some zucchinis
but it's getting it's getting to be a
lot but i think that because you're
getting into this farming language that
when you get into dating again
you're going to talk about your dating
life but you're going to be using
farming terminology you're going to be
saying like well
lately i've been dating a penis is not
thriving they're not thriving they're
not developing i don't know what the
problem is
this penis is not ready to harvest
i don't think it's ready right now
let me see your nails let me see those
nails nicole look at those now what's
going on there
so i got into fake nails i miss having
my long nails can't go to a salon i
refuse to die for my nails
so i ordered them online and they they
look pretty good they make me happy
you look fantastic can i see a close-up
of the uh it looks like there's
translucent ones yes
this one it's like see-through look at
that
it almost looks like you could have
little goldfish in there swimming around
i wish because then i could take my
little pet goldfish everywhere with me
let me ask you a question why is it that
women get to do that but men
can't i mean why can't i get fake nails
you can get fake nails gender is a
construct
uh gendered clothing is insane you can
wear
whatever you want promise all right you
know what i'm going to do
you funny but just go hello i'm conan
o'brien
i'm thriving i'm doing well i want fake
nails
and i'm living you know what next time
that you and i
are together in the same space i want to
get fake nails put on
we'll do that you want me fully in drag
yeah heels and everything you'd be the
tallest drag queen you've also got a
nice slender body so
clothing would just hang off of you
you've got a full head of hair so maybe
we could do like
a little like a short maybe slick do i
i see it for you so you think i'd make a
great drag queen
yes i think you'd be stunning i actually
might be a lot more attractive
in drag i think it's cause you gotta
stop with this whole self-deprecating
thing
you're stunning you have all of your
teeth
your skin is so smooth and you have two
eyes
thank you for setting the lowest bar
ever
for me nicole
you have functioning eyes your ocular
jelly is in the orbits and it's
functioning
so you're gorgeous yes you're right well
you've pumped me up i now think i'm a
male model so
thank you very much for that i want to
congratulate you also
because your podcast why don't you date
me which by the way
i do want to mention uh is now part of
the team coco podcast network and we're
thrilled to be working with you because
you are hilarious
and lovely and very entertaining always
but your podcast won
a big award you won best female
host for a podcast there's like a
million podcasts out there and you
won and you beat out some huge
competition
yes it's because i host four podcasts at
this
point so they were like i don't know she
has them all we have to give her an
award
you're being a little modest uh i think
you did deserve to win
well i'm happy for you i'm glad that
your uh
leg is on the mend why won't you date me
is available wherever you can get your
podcasts
and wipeout is going to be coming soon
to tbs congratulations on that
thank you you are crazy busy i don't
know how you do it but i'm glad you're
doing it oh thank you conan all right
and uh
i will talk to you soon yes okay bye bye
conan